hi I'm here with Sam Levine I'm an
emotional fluffer so as you know as soon
as you walk in that door you're up for
grabs so you can be rested at any moment
in time my goodness I didn't know
emotional fluffer was a job title I've
been filling out my unemployment records
all wrong yeah well I get paid so I'm
technically employee fair enough if you
were to be roasted do you have anything
that you'd be afraid of people it's a
deal if my lift just comes out when I
talk about it so please don't talk about
it it's a pretty strong list thank you
so much last time they like called me
they said I had a flat ass which is true
like come at me anything you could ever
say about me I've already thought about
myself that's exactly and I'm excited
honestly I'll be I'm like did Martha
Stewart Google me
like she had to like maybe go I'm like
so flattered I'm pretty thick-skinned I
don't get embarrassed that easily I
wrote on the row so you're already so
talented you just nothing affects yeah I
just yeah you should got you if you were
getting roasted what would you be afraid
that people would make funny before any
youtube comment that has called me a fat
bitch I'm afraid people are gonna call
me a fat oh well you're looking great
thank you you too darling thing I have
to say you're the least threatening man
and as a man in Hollywood right now that
is the nicest thing I could oh thanks
I'm an emotional fluffer so my job is to
get you hard you get up there okay it's
ready to go I'm ready
I mean smoking hot well thanks
you look I'm holding a few retirees
don't die by the way check the other
clip on Shirley I want you to meet my
dad and my daddy all right I mean I
think I do
are you ready are you ready to be
roasted Dulce you're so fine you sound
like a candy you should be good diver
because I want to go get diving in your
panty drawer for your girl more like
Adam lusting for that day
you're so sweet to your guests
decepticon be probably the only guy to
probably get bros - the most besides
Bruce Willis I know you're known for
your rebalance and I would love to
rebound with you you know what I mean
I'm gonna be thinking about you I'm
gonna be you said you've wide-open WFO
baby white females only
you